JOANNA SMITH: If you have
some heavy work to do
and it doesn't need
to be done right now,
then I'm going to kindly
ask you to use JobScheduler.
JobScheduler is guaranteed
to get your job done.
But since it operates
at the system level,
it can use several factors
to intelligently schedule
your background work to run
with the jobs from other apps
as well, and that means
we can minimize things
like radio use, which
is a clear battery win.
And as of API 24,
JobScheduler even
considers memory pressure,
which is a clear overall win
for devices and their users.
JobScheduler was
introduced in Lollipop
and is pretty cool, because
it doesn't perform work solely
based on time, but rather
based on conditions.
For example, you can use
setRequiredNetworkType for jobs
that you want to
execute when the user is
on a metered versus an
unmetered connection
or you can call
setPersisted for jobs
that you want to persist
across a potential reboot.
And as of API 24,
there are even methods
to schedule a job based on an
update to a content provider.
And of course, you can
read the documentation
to see how to play with other
criteria you might care about,
from backoff policies to time
limits for scheduling the job.
Basically, this is
where the magic happens,
so spend some time
getting it right.
You can define these conditions
when you are creating the job
through the JobInfo object.
To build that JobInfo object,
you need two things every time,
and then the criteria are all
the bonus that's over here.
But you need a
job number to help
you distinguish which job
this is and a job service.
Now, your job
service is actually
going to be a service that
extends the JobService class,
and this is where you'll define
the work that you'll be doing.
But since you're
extending another class,
you will need to implement
a few required methods.
OnStartJob is called by
the system when it is
time for your job to execute.
This is where the one tricky
part about JobScheduler exists.
Your JobService runs
on the main thread.
That's right, the main thread.
So use onStartJob to
either perform simple work
or to kick off a background
thread for complicated work.
And if you do kick
off something else,
you'll need to return true.
But if you're done
with everything,
go ahead and return false.
This will let the system
know whether your job has
any ongoing work still.
OnStopJob is called
by the system
if your job is canceled
before being finished, perhaps
because the conditions
are no longer being met,
like the device
has been unplugged.
So use this for safety
checks and clean up, and then
return true if you'd like the
system to reschedule the job
or false if it doesn't matter
and the job will be dropped.
JobFinished is not a
method you override,
and the system won't
call it, but that's
because you need to
be the one to call
this method once your
service or thread has
finished working on the job.
That is, if your
onStartJob returned true,
because this is how
the system knows
that your work is
really done and it
can release your wakelock.
So if you forget,
your app is going
to look pretty guilty in
the battery stats lineup.
JobFinished takes two
parameters, the current job,
so that it knows which
one we are talking about,
and a Boolean,
indicating whether you'd
like to reschedule the job.
Perhaps your work
failed for some reason.
So this will kick off
the JobScheduler's
exponential backoff
logic for you
or else the logic you
specified in JobInfo.
Now, as with any
service, you'll need
to add this one to your
AndroidManifest.xml.
What's different,
though, is that you
need to add a permission
that will allow JobScheduler
to call your jobs and
be the only one that
can access your JobService.
Finally, you can
schedule a job using
JobScheduler, which you
will get from the system,
then call schedule using that
super perfect JobInfo object
you created, and
you are good to go.
Not so scary, is that?
There are a lot of
pieces to be sure,
and you'll need
to think carefully
about when and what
should trigger your job
and what happens if it
fails for some reason.
But overall,
JobScheduler was designed
to be easy to work with.
So give it a try and
go build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]